avenges endgame isn't done giving up its
secrets in the wake of the marvel flex
home release funds are beginning to
scour every frame for Easter eggs they
may have missed in the theatres in fact
a big one has recently come to light
involving a villain who just seems to
keep popping up you'll remember that an
endgame second act Steve Rogers and Tony
Stark are forced to use that last Pym
particle to travel back to the 1970s in
an attempt to secure the space stone
after their attempt to do so join their
trip to the Battle of New York goes
pear-shaped do you even know what an
idiom is colloquial metaphor know it
well okay actually yes the pair
infiltrate the shield facility where the
Infinity stone is being housed and in
the course of the mission Stark is
thrown for a loop when he runs into his
father Howard drawing their conversation
Howard mentions Arnim Zola the Hydra
scientist who was captured by the agency
that will become shield droney events of
Captain America the First Avenger Zola
was pressed into the service of shield
but of course the nefarious scientists
had a hidden agenda to assist in
spreading hydras influence within the
organization we subsequently learned in
Captain America the Winter Soldier that
this effort was a smashing success and
that she would have been infiltrated by
Hydra scum to its very highest levels we
also learned that Zola who had long
since died had digitized his
consciousness uploading it into a
massive Bank of old-school computers as
a way of making sure that he would
continue to have influence over shields
inner workings the new Hydra crew a
beautiful parasite inside
Zola's Winter Soldier appearance
concluded with him destroying the bunker
that held his digital self in a bid to
blow up Cap'n Natasha but in 1970 he
still existed as a fleshy shield
scientist however there's evidence that
his plans to digitizers code within
shields mainframe was already in effect
by the time Tony edits impromptu family
reunion on a desk in Howard's labs it's
an old-school computer terminal and if
you look closely you can see that solar
screen low-res message graces as monitor
the folks as city's side's pointed out
this blink in your misuk cameo in their
behind the scenes breakdown of the end
game VFX not only is there a brilliant
callback to one of the best films of the
MCU it serves as a distinct nods a Zola
himself in the comics Zola has inhabited
a robotic body since the waning days of
World War 2 and he keeps multiple spare
bodies on hands in the event that his
primary body is damaged or destroyed
could this be a way for the filmmakers
leave the door open fair's potential
return to the MCU at some point after
all who's to save didn't maintain a
secondary site housing a backup copy of
himself before self-destructing in the
Winter Soldier this is a man with a
seriously inflated sense of his own
importance and there's nobody more loyal
to Hydra and general villainy once the
purification process is complete hydras
new order perhaps this will come into
play when Falcon and the Winter Soldier
the first of the Disney Plus limited
series set within the MCU drops late
next year parts of the series focus will
be Sam Wilson's struggle of taking on
the mantle of Captain America bequeathed
to him by Rogers himself attend the
game's conclusion if there's one thing
we know about Zola outside of us
unwavering loyalty to Hydra I studied
really hates Captain America and we
dealt it with matter who's taking up the
mantle this ceased to ragas and
outwardly one of a hundred or so that
will become known and now that ends
gamers received his home release check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos buy your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bell to you don't miss a single one
[Music]